Many say size matters, but when it comes down
to business, I'm here to tell you, it's all
about how you position yourself.
And let me tell you why this is great news
for you.
Here's why.
Let's just say you're the David of your industry,
going against Goliath.
Let's just say you're a small company, you're
a small guy.
You got a smaller operation, and these people
are massive!
They're sitting on billions of dollars of
assets and you don't have that type of assets.
So how do you compete against them, right?
Because a lot of times I'll talk to entrepreneurs
and they'll say, "You know what, Patrick?
I have a printing company.
And I want to do business cards and I also
want to do magazines and I also want to do
books.
And I also want to do brochures.
And I also want to do flip charts.
And I also want to do this and I also want
to do banners.
I want to do everything.
Because I want to be able to get.
. . there's these companies that do business
cards and they make a lot of money.
What if I do all of it?"
Right?
Or a lot of times people will say, I'm in
the financial services.
I want to do real estate, I want to do loans.
I want to do escrow.
I want to do processing.
I want to do underwriting.
I want to do title.
I want to do it all!
Because if I do it all, I can be so big.
That, logically, may make sense, but it's
the dumbest way for someone to position themselves.
And, I'll tell you, and validate on a couple
of stories, why.
I got two companies here, to give you an example
of.
One, we have Heinz.
The other one here we have Haloid.
I'll start off with Haloid.
Some of you may say, who is Haloid?
I don't even know who Haloid is.
Who is Haloid?
Let me tell you who Haloid is.
Haloid is actually the first company ever
to come out with personal computers.
Now some of you guys are watching and saying,
c'mon, Pat.
Wasn't it IBM?
IBM came out with those big computers.
But Haloid is the first one that came out
with the smaller computers.
The story is fascinating!
They came out with these smaller computers.
They were the first ones to come out with
a mouse.
Steve Jobs was the first one to launch mouse
to the world.
But they were the first ones that came out
with mouse.
They were the first ones that came out with
a small keyboard.
It was literally this big.
If you go type in right now online, Xerox
Alto.
And the reason why it's called Xerox Alto
is because originally it was called Xerox
Palo Alto, they dropped the Palo.
It's called Xerox Alto.
It came out in 1973, stay with me here with
the numbers.
When it came out in 1973, they only produced
2,000 of them.
A thousand for their employees, 500 for universities,
and 500 they kept.
They never marketed this product!
Never.
Until one day, a guy, who lives in Palo Alto
calls them and says, hey, I hear you guys
got this machine that I want to see.
And I'm getting ready to start a company and
I'm willing to give you this company of mine,
I'll give you 100,000 shares for a million
dollars.
I just want you to allow me to see this machine.
And this guy walks into Haloid's entire place
in 1978, 1979ish, and he walks in.
And the guy's looking and says, This is a
mouse?
How come you're not selling this to the public?
Do you realize.
. . and he gets antsy, and can't control himself,
jumping all over the place.
They say this guy was so excited.
He couldn't even hold himself together.
And he said, do you guys realize how powerful?
How many have you made of this?
Only 2,000.
Oh my gosh!
Three days he's taking notes from morning
till night, he's just taking notes.
Taking notes.
He keeps coming back, keeps coming back.
Taking notes, taking notes, taking notes.
You know who that guy is?
Boom!
Steve Jobs.
Steve Jobs goes to this place, sees a big,
dumb company, who does not realize what this
computer could be.
The PC personal computer, if they sold it
to the public, they didn't see the vision.
They fully didn't see the vision.
So look what happens to them.
Apple takes over, comes out and one day, Steve
Jobs launches this mouse, and everybody says,
"this guy's such a visionary!"
He got the mouse from Haloid, Alto product,
Xerox Alto product that he saw, but he launched
it to the public.
2,000 computers, 1,000 for employees, 500
for universities, 500 they kept, Apple gave
it to the world.
And Apple today is worth 400 billion dollars.
Now watch what happens here.
A few years later, 1973, they launch it.
Eight years later, Haloid decides we should
probably consider launching this computer.
And they do in 1980.
You know for how much?
For $100,000.
How many people you think can afford $100,000
computer?
In 1981!
Think about how much $100,000 is today.
$100,000 in today's dollars is like 400, $500,000.
We're talking $100,000 to buy a PC computer
in 1981.
So guess what happens?
It flops.
The best thing Haloid did, at that moment,
they realized they were way behind the eight
ball.
Way behind the eight ball.
Apple's taking a lead on everybody.
Then these other companies are coming up,
the Compaq, the Atari, you know, all these
other companies are coming up.
And Haloid's in the back.
Now Haloid has a machine that they make, that's
called Xerox.
And so Xerox becomes the number one copy machine.
On computers, Haloid is ranked #10.
So they said, yes, we can go compete with
computers, but you know what?
Why don't we reposition ourselves because
it's about positioning, not size.
Haloid dropped their entire computer company.
They lost $84 million, when they just wrote
it off.
You know what they did?
They said, "Let's just position ourselves
with copy machines."
We're not a computer company.
We completely missed out here [computers],
let's go over here [copy machines].
A big, dumb company made a mistake.
They were honest about the fact that they
made a mistake.
The repositioned, and saved themselves, and
Xerox today, still, it is a Fortune 500 company,
$24.8 billion company today.
They dominate the copy machine marketplace.
Because they repositioned.
Let me come on this side.
Heinz - many, many years ago, Heinz was selling
pickles, they still do today, and they were
doing baby food.
And they were so focused on baby food, and
they were so focused on pickles, but they
were always ranked top five in pickles, and
they were ranked top five in baby food.
It was always Gerber, Vlasic, they just couldn't
beat them.
When you think about pickles, you think about
Vlasic.
When you think about baby food, you think
about Gerber.
They just couldn't beat those guys.
So it's like, man, let's go against size.
These guys are bigger, I'm getting tired.
I'm David trying to go against Goliath, who's
selling all these pickles.
And they're selling all this.
I can't.
I'm tired.
How do I go against these big guys?
They're killing me.
Huh.
What are we number one in?
We are number one in ketchup.
What the hell are we thinking about?
Why don't we just say, "Forget about this."
Let's put 5% of our time and resources into
this.
Let's put 95% of our time into ketchup."
And so they repositioned themselves, and went
to ketchup.
Today when I think about Heinz, and I tell
you Heinz, what do you think about?
Do you think about Heinz pickles?
C'mon.
You think about Heinz baby food [chuckles].
You don't even know Heinz has baby food, right?
You think about one thing.
You think about ketchup.
When I tell you Xerox today, do you even think
about Haloid?
Did you even know that Haloid started the
first personal computer?
Did you even know that Haloid came out with
the first 2,000 PCs that they only used for
themselves and universities.
Did you know that?
I didn't know that.
People didn't know that.
Now you study and you say, Oh my.
They missed out.
But they repositioned themselves.
So now let's come back to you.
It's all about you.
Let's talk about you now.
You're running a business.
What are you selling?
What are you trying to sell?
Are you trying to sell anything and everything
everybody's coming up with?
I remember when I was running the business
and I was selling insurance, and it was securities
at that time.
So I'm a Series 7, 66, 31, 26 life and health.
I came from Morgan Stanley.
So I started off with stocks.
Then I transitioned to mutual funds, and money
under management.
Then it was variable universal life policies
and VULs, and variable annuities.
And then I saw everybody that was fighting
for certain pieces of the pie.
I want this.
I want that.
And then finally, I had to reposition myself.
There was a guy in the valley, they were doing
mortgages, making $400,000 a month.
Pat, you need to get into mortgages.
I am this close, this close of getting into
mortgages.
Oh, you got to get into real estate.
I'm this close.
Pat, we got to get into, I'm telling you,
title reps are making 600 grand a year.
All you got to do is drop off some doughnuts
to these loan officers, man.
It's so easy, making 600 grand a year with
titles.
I said, "No!"
Positioning.
No one wants to touch life insurance.
Nobody wants to touch life insurance.
More business for us!
No one.
Everybody wants to sell variable universal
life.
Not for us.
Everybody, everybody, everybody.
Nope, this is our positioning.
And we compete in this positioning.
Today we're number one in specific products
in the entire world.
We're number one in this one specific product.
Why?
Positioning.
You cannot be everything to everybody.
Come back to you.
How many different products do you sell?
Who are you trying to be?
What is your main flagship product?
Do you have a flagship product?
What is your flagship product?
What do you sell?
What are you mainly marketing?
What is it that you've got going on?
Are you positioning it right?
Or are you constantly trying to fight the
big guy?
Are you trying to position yourself to say,
"I'm going to go against the big guy?"
Are you saying, "Nope.
I'm going to reposition myself to go after
this market, because no one's touching this."
If you can take an hour or two, listen, New
Year's right here, it's the first video of
Valuetainment you're watching outside of probably
Motivation Monday.
New Year's right here.
How are you going to reposition yourself in
'17?
How are you going to do it?
Do you have a plan for it?
What are you going to be?
Do you want to be the big guy of this, that's
already there's 50 of them out there, and
you want to compete with this guy?
How are you going to reposition yourself?
It's almost like saying you're going to go
into politics, and you're campaigning, and
everybody's campaigning around let's pick
something, give me a subject on politics that
some people campaign around.
Let's just say economics.
Let's just say pro-life, pro-choice.
Let's just say you got military.
Let's just say you got this.
And it's like you're running for campaign,
and you're saying, I'm going to build a wall.
You know why you say that?
It's positioning.
No one's talking about that.
And then all the politicians are saying, what?
The same old thing.
And they lose.
Some people look at Valuetainment and say,
Pat, how come it's not all the motivation
like some of these other channels all the
time.
You're actually doing how-to.
Man, we repositioned ourselves.
We get a lot of heat.
We get a lot of mail and hate mail, Pat, we
think what you're doing is wrong.
What am I doing wrong?
You shouldn't give all this content out for
free.
You should sell it for a few thousand dollars.
I'm not doing that.
That's not fair, man.
This is how we make a living.
I'm losing people to Valuetainment.
I don't care about that.
You charge it for free.
Yeah, but my business is getting people to
buy my recordings on webinars and I get them
to pay a thousand dollars and if I get 1,000
people to pay for this, this is how I make
a living.
I make a living by giving the content away
and I run a real business.
And I want to help entrepreneurs around the
world.
This is our positioning.
What's your positioning?
By the way, we can go into sports and say
the same thing.
We can go into baseball and say the same thing.
You can go into Hollywood and say the same
thing.
You can go into basketball, church, religion,
business, body building, so many different
things.
As long as you reposition yourself properly,
you have an edge.
If you're trying to be everybody else, you
are constantly going to be fighting against
size, and eventually you're comparing yourself
to the wrong person.
You can't compete against the size.
You got to figure out a way to reposition
yourself.
And there's a way you can do it in your business.
There's a way you can do it in your business.
But you got to put some time into it and think
about it, because you know we have, and you've
got to constantly adjust as well.
Because some people may come back and say,
well what do you have to say about Apple?
Apple went into computers and they repositioned
themselves into phones because phones are.
. . yes, because it's called sometimes you've
got to call an audible.
Here's the football, ready, boom, boom, boom,
boom, audible.
You got to do the same.
Sometimes if Apple realized everything's going
away from computers, we're going to tablets,
what if we make a phone that's a tablet?
And it's a smartphone.
Then they dominate.
Then we have to change.
Is it watch?
I don't know if it's the watch.
Is it Fitbit?
What is the next thing?
You have to adapt.
And this is why Apple could be the next BDC
[big dumb company].
There's a lot of BDCs out there.
Anybody could be a BDC.
Haloid's not the only BDC out there.
There's a lot of BDCs out there.
You just need to figure out a way to reposition
yourself.
Anyway, I can go and talk about this subject
for hours and have a lot of fun with it, but
I'll leave it to what it's at right now, without
getting too deep into it.
Hey, it's exciting times, it's 2017!
Man, time flies.
Just yesterday was Y2K, and everybody was
trying to set aside pickle jars and food and,
you know, Heinz was making a lot of money,
because of all these things you were setting
aside because all the banks, they don't know
how to handle zero, and 17 years later it's
2017 and more gray hair for me.
And if you want to find out if you're aging,
always look at this part of your hand.
This part doesn't lie.
We all look young here [palm].
You can tell your age right here.
Time is flying, baby.
Don't get casual.
We only got a limited time to make a big impact
in the world and I hope you're part of it,
as we go out there and revolutionize this
entire way of educating entrepreneurship around
the world, which we are just getting started.
Stay tuned for some crazy things that we'll
be launching here pretty soon.
Anyways, if you haven't subscribed to Valuetainment,
please do so.
And I don't really know what you're waiting
for.
We need your help to sub, and click the alert
button as well, so you get the updates every
time these videos come out.
And if you got any questions, any thoughts
about today's video, comment on the bottom.
I literally go through every single comment,
still, till today.
It's getting tougher, but I still read through
every single comment.
And I look forward to seeing your comments.
Take care everybody.
Bye bye.